in this video we're gonna talk about how to
flush an hplc column in order to maximize
column life this is especially important to do
if you add buffers or additives to your mobile
phase for instance most people use something
like ammonium acetate or formic acid etc over
time if the column isn't flushed out regularly
precipitates can form and it can plug up your
column thereby destroying it we're going to show
you two techniques to extend your column life
as much as possible the first method is your daily
maintenance method if you have a solenoid valve
in your pump you can select up to four solvents
a and b solvents can be used as your standard
mobile phases for regular operations c
and d then can be selected and used as
solvents for cleaning c and d would normally consist
of water and some kind of organic solvent like
methanol you can simply do a gradient after your
last run of five percent to 95% over an hour and
that should keep things nice and clean if you
don't have a solenoid valve you're just gonna
have to switch the bottles if you feel like your
column needs a deeper cleaning it would be best
to do a reverse flush you start by disconnecting
the column at the low pressure end and then the
high pressure end don't forget to remove the guard
lastly you flip the column around and you can flow
into a container so you don't dirty your detector
the method for reverse flush would be to start
with 95 percent water and 5 methanol for about 10column volumes. Then you do a gradient of 5% to 95%
methanol for five column volumes and lastly
you hold five percent water and 95% methanol
for 10 column volumes you want to run this at
half of your normal flow rates for your method
the way that you know it's time to do a deeper
cleaning is to monitor your pressure buildup on
your column always note the back pressure when you
first install the column so you have a baseline if
you notice your pressure kick up around 15 to
20 percent it's a good idea to do the reverse
flush that's it for the tutorial today i hope that
helps you keep your column clean if you like this
type of content please like and subscribe it'll
really help us out a lot see you in the next video